[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
the honest trailer commentary for
invincible a show that i enjoyed but had
to make honest trailers about anyways
with me as always island and danielle
uh we'll be talking about our behind the
scenes in-depth thoughts behind the show
and our thought process we will be
talking about deleted scenes because we
have a few of those this time
um and uh we'll kind of tease you with
next week's honest trailer as well as
respond to questions and comments from
angry viewers like yourselves uh this
was a fun
show that i liked a lot uh i actually
watched it not thinking we were gonna do
an honest trailer about it
but man everybody really uh banged on
the rafters until we did one so
good job fans uh commenting works
sometimes
keep it up um i just watched this
because i actually
uh you know in a rare moment read the
comics first and enjoy the comics for
invisible and was like oh
they made a show of this great um and
you know it suffers from i think the
usual
oddly low budget animation of like they
save all the money for the fight scenes
uh and then the rest of the time they
just kind of kind of anime it in
um come on bezos you're going to space
you can
take a little more joe on some level
though didn't you feel like that was
intentional i felt like this was
supposed to take us back in time to like
the 80s and 90s when tv animation was
just
a little cruder the budget constraints
of a saturday morning cartoon
yeah like i mean i'm not obviously a
lower budget
works great for everybody i'm sure that
was on purpose but
i do think that they wanted it to have
that throwback sort of out-of-time
feel i'm just surprised this is as
popular as it is uh what what'd you
think danielle what's your invincible
takes
um well so yeah i also read the comic
and i really really uh
really liked the uh the animation
um it's i was surprised that people
liked it as much too
i think it was one of those things where
um it was just kind of right place right
time
but also it is just really good it's a
really good story it's told very well
um the violence i think surprised a lot
of people and for some people i do think
that that was kind of a hook
in where it was like oh well this ain't
is ain't your mama's superhero origin
story
um and so i think that that definitely
contributed to
some of the popularity of it because
some of y'all are sick you're sick
people
sick little puppies um yeah you need and
you need a hook at this point because as
we point out there are a million of
these subversions of superhero
shows going um to the point where
uh this one this one came out in 2003
the comic came out in 2003 they were
already uh making fun of superhero
tropes back then
um at least the comics this kind of has
like uh
it's like mystery men where like it came
it came out way too soon like the comic
i think came out too soon
but uh like if mystery men came out
today it'd be a huge hit
so you're right i think this was the
right place right time for invincible
um well i mean should we just dive in i
mean it's a
it's a good show that we all enjoy it's
it's kind of a rare occurrence so let's
uh
let's watch you on this trailer
is taco down there taco is right here
being
his usual bother i'm trying to try to
get it to go
by making it more grounded relationship
focused and hyper violent comes a
reinvention of the superhero genre
that makes it more grounded relationship
focused and hyper violent
look out movie musicals you're about to
get kirkmanned
pause i mean we say you do that like
it's like it's easy to do that like
no it's very difficult robert kirkman's
very good at what he does yeah
um yeah i also though would watch the
the bleeding butthole cut of cats
i it's very i i really wrestled when i i
wrote that that opening
like what genre to to have look out
blank you're next uh i i thought of
musicals and then i ended up picking uh
what i wrote at disaster movies and i
thought
maybe like the big um independence day
like the white house blowing up but we
just put
blood everywhere instead of just the
light show but i think
cat's the butthole cut work any any
excuse to see
james corden bleeding from his posterior
that's an honest trailer promise yeah i
i i you know i i was worried that um
changing it to musicals might be just a
little like
i don't know corny or the easy answer
but then when you see it all come
together visually and you see
james sometimes it just it changes
important decisions always being made um
all right keep going
invincible from lexcorp
comes another grim story about how
superheroes would behave if they were
real
no the other one no the other one on
amazon
meet mark grayson an ordinary teen who
discovers he's secretly part alien
and possibly part canadian sorry i'll be
right back
sorry about your apartment sorry about
this i've been there
and i'm sorry i didn't realize that
sooner sorry
sorry i just assumed because of that
canada shirt
that this did take place in canada so i
was like oh
uh i think the first version of this
joke in my head was like
come on omni man like you you you want
your son to take over the world like you
raised him in canada you can't even get
him to punch anyone without saying sorry
first or something like that
but it takes place in chicago or alt
chicago right thing like that like yeah
so what's going on there what what
what's with that canada i guess the
actor i think stephen young and sandra
oh are canadian
so it's like a maybe he's half canadian
can someone unravel the canada mystery
for me
maybe he's just polite spencer
like there are polite americans it's not
exclusively a canadian feature
or he's just a canadian stan boy he just
really loves canada
he's appropriating canadian culture by
apologizing for everything it is odd
unless it's like a sport like if it's
like team canada i guess that would be a
thing but it is
otherwise odd to just like wear a shirt
about your favorite country it's like
i mean i guess like tourists maybe if
you go to like ireland you get a shirt
that says ireland on it but otherwise
it's like a weird
weird flex but okay i mean the back of
every t-shirt i own
says like this is america and if you can
read this
too close and if you think you're dating
my daughter i
am a mechanic and my wife is a
registered nurse and we live
in kentucky and we're both virgos yeah
and if you've got a problem with that
yeah the text gets
really small by the end yeah take it out
with my ar-15
yeah there's a lot to be said back here
yeah you got to get you got to work your
way down
keep going hi sorry sorry
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
so sorry i am so
sorry i know i'm sorry
i suck he's in every man for the zoomer
generation
which means he's extremely depressed
horny and resents having to actually do
anything with his abilities
i can't believe i still have to exercise
but he'll have to harness all of his
strength to battle exotic villains
protect his friends and gain one single
clue across an entire season of
television
hey i didn't invent the rules what rules
it's kind of like peeing your pants on
purpose what
what's going on what oh
okay there's so much you don't know mark
what
okay your superman and your dad is
thanos mark you are a comic book nerd
you should get this immediately yeah so
pause i mean this was something that we
talked about but didn't quite fit in
maybe it's in a deleted scene it's like
the prevalence of superheroes in this
universe
they seem like they're everywhere like
they dominate pop culture and like
there's so many
there's like four different teen
superhero teams like working i guess
in chicago and stuff like that like
why how could you be an outsider to this
world
like and they even make a point of
showing that he's a big comic book nerd
which i guess is like
are they all autobiographical like is
there a saying
i think they're doing the thing i think
they're doing the watchmen thing
where their comic books in their world
are not about superheroes because
superheroes are an everyday thing for
them
so they're about like dogs with powers
and stuff like that's why in watchmen
the big comic is about pirates because
you wouldn't
you wouldn't care about like a superhero
is already exists
so i thought i thought that's what they
were doing with sandstock it's like oh
he reads a comic that's about a
psychic dog because that's still not
real in his world that is a hundred
percent
in the realm of reality in the
invincible
yeah but he still gets surprised when he
meets like an alien like it's not that
every day for him yeah i mean it
is though his dad's an alien it's no it
yeah i mean it's a
it becomes it's sort of almost like the
john wick series like at first it's just
like
oh wow there's a lot of undercover
assassins around but by three it's like
literally the entire city of new york is
an assassin right and this is
truly the superhero universe maybe the
boys but even then that i would
least like to live in because it just
seems like
24 7 chaos like how many people
are victims of collateral damage in this
universe cause
they keep destroying the like everything
is commonplace destroying the city
destroying the white house
uh destroying monuments like just no no
thank you
i will take my chances which universe do
you think you'd be safer in
this universe or the grand theft auto
universe because that's what it feels
like it feels a bit like if you just
lived in liberty city like at any minute
somebody could just round the corner and
drive over you
i mean i guess grand theft auto because
i feel like there's only like
as long as there's only one person
playing at a time not grand theft auto
online
right gta online obviously is what i
meant
okay never mind yeah i'm just dropping
you into los santos good luck
hey cj all right go again
here we go again get to know wild
characters
a guy with the most intimidating
superpower of all
dad strength he's mark's father and a
clever subversion of every boy's fantasy
that their dad could beat up your dad
like this there's also amber mark's
girlfriend
who totally cracked his secret identity
totally
you know i'm not an idiot i figured it
out weeks ago
who was that the police are on their way
where the hell did you go
sandra oh in a dual role as an important
character's mother
and a different important character's
wife and the guardians of the globe
the washington general oh i guess it's a
deleted scene but yeah uh
lon you point out that sandra o's
character is to get in the way
of what the heroes want to do and thus
become a villain
it's both zayzi beats and sandra oh's
character
are in the skyler for breaking bad roles
where they if you look at it from their
perspective
perfectly logical all the things they're
doing is saying but because they're
they become the antagonist because we
want the heroes to do whatever they want
so like
the audience is like no but i want walt
to go back to making meth skyler stop
spoiling it but like but any rational
woman would be like well you need to
stop doing this this is great yeah
i want to see the uh father-son punch
off
don't get don't get in the way of that a
lot on the man to blow up the entire
subway system
that's fine don't stop it is
is there like a maybe is this in the
comics or something like
is she loki an alcoholic like she's
hitting the sauce or is it just regular
mom drinking levels
yeah i think she's just a regular old
wine mom regular wine mom levels okay
eat praying and loving yeah somewhere on
their wall is a framed poster that says
uh it's wine o'clock one o'clock
somewhere
yeah okay keep going kingdom generals of
superhero teams
they're here to do two important things
kill time
until invincible or any man shows up and
use their superpowers to get around age
of consent laws
i don't look it but i'm 24 years old i'm
a 30 year old genius
in a teenage boy's body i never expanded
myself to that extent
that was so positive i also assume that
this
is going to factor in more in season two
and three but like we spend
a lot of time with the guardians of the
globe and they do not matter
in the grand scheme of things at all yet
right like they are just kind of they're
just kind of filler
i mean they're interesting characters
but when you think like the world
they've created there's there's
omniman and the vitruvians it's like if
you if you kept cutting to
i don't know netflix daredevil in the
middle of
in the middle of captain marvel or
something like that
yeah no they don't seem like they're
very uh
but i think it's just it's good to to
build the characters and i do think that
they're gonna wind up playing more of a
thing in season two because we've got to
see those two
people who aren't teens and teen bodies
go on dates
and that's very important yeah i mean
i think you could have probably left
them behind once adam eve
kind of split off um
but i don't know i think that by the
same token though or
is like that i think is the most fun
part of the world is like there's just
kind of this parade of different
vibrant superhero characters that is
just kind of fun to be around like the
villains especially like the recurring
villains and like doc
seismic and stuff like that and these
little guys that would kind of recur
in the background here and there like
that i think is what's fun and it's like
kirkman just kind of playing around in
this universe
um i agree to me at its best this felt a
bit like a
more serious and and weighty venture
brothers like
that that we're creating this kind of
alt universe where any kind of pop
culturey
pulp sort of character can exist and so
these creative writers just get to like
fill every corner in with like funny
weird interesting little ideas and like
i think at its best that's what this
does where it's just like
all of these fun like one-off weird
things that kirkman
or one of the writers came up with that
they just get to like
spend ten minutes on and then okay we're
off to the next adventure i don't have
to really flesh this out much
yeah you love to see it exactly like
that that's that's the highlight of this
explore a vast and entirely original
comic book universe
when it was first published back in 2003
that took care to update some of the old
tropes
but still has a ton of jokes you'll be
hearing the second time around
like clones who can't decide which one
is the original i'm the original
he told me you're the clone what do you
think he told me you're the clown you're
gonna do rick and morty one of these
secretly specialize in hero costumes
i'll strive for iconic
knuckles a friendly alien voiced by seth
rogen
are you using your timeout it's probing
time and
robot-headed mafia bosses i've got
money it gives me no joy to do this
because clamps will be doing it geez
there are multiple animated comedies
featuring wacky robot godfathers
maybe we should try a new genre once in
a while hey anyone up for bringing back
the horny skies trailer
this is the new allen clips from ski
school your love of
ski comedies is uh legend in the
artist's trailer writer's room yeah uh
uh
i didn't know how to when in doubt show
a clip from ski school or is that ski
patrol i'll have to go back and check
oh i thought that was ski school right
you're right ski patrol is the one
that's definitely ski school yeah ski
patrol is the one with the guy who has
like the three different like heads on
his
ski helmet right yeah i assumed we were
going to use we were going to pull from
out cold so i was surprised to see yeah
i feel like how cold is the sort of the
iconic one for this generation
and i try to we got to just rip the
whole movie because i wanted to do the
scene
where the guy skis into the hot tub but
i could only find this one
when are we doing every ski comedy ever
what is that on australia it'll be my
final honest trip
that's yours nobody
and will uh want to watch the show after
that all right keep going
[Music]
so marvel at a show so dance with ayla's
celebrities it's super clear that amazon
can afford to give its drivers bathroom
breaks
or at least improve the animation when
it's not part of the fight scene in this
show that combines the look of a 90s
cartoon
with tons of fun twists recurring jokes
and
hey wait that wasn't done okay why would
you drop the credits like that
the episode clearly isn't over there's
like two more minutes left
see starring young justice
get me pictures of omni man wait i'll do
it how i pet your mother
i wish that i had joker's girl
calm the pink ranger doltron
jason mandzukic as himself you'll do
what
i don't know probably explode something
oh
maybe you think yes and subway we can
all agree that
jason mandzukic uh while perhaps being
typecast or onenote is
is a huge societal improvement over uh
tj miller
i feel like he's just taken all of those
roles and i don't definitely if it's a
vocal role man sukis is just just in
there
just lightly segwayed in there
he's super funny even when he shows up
he did the league right
um and he's in this show i'm sorry that
i
that i love but got cancelled um he's
good oh he's doing it
he's in a ton of stuff right now like i
feel like he's in big mouth obviously
and who could forget tick-tock mr wood
he's the tick-tock man
he's back in week four uh but yeah i
feel like he's having like a real
like moment now too there's a lot of
like upcoming animated shows and stuff
that
he's going to pop up and so all tj
miller had to do was not call in a bomb
threat on a train that he was
no and like several other things not be
horrible to everyone for 20 years if he
could have just managed that he would be
right now okay anyways keep going
and subway eat fresh
splotchmen
did you guys notice the invisible shirt
that i put in that other movie where i
voiced an alien you see you plant the
seed and then you the plant
[Laughter]
john really wanted to do his uh central
concept it's good
it's a good road
anyways uh thank you all for watching
please like and subscribe and hit the
bell if you haven't you know how a
youtube channel works this is one of
those
and it helps uh when you hit the little
ring-a-ding-dong so you can see us
every time we do one of these which is
often um
every every tuesday i feel like every
tuesday yeah
um and more stuff like the loki video
that we uh had a real therapist uh
diagnosed loki
and and give him a treatment plan it
involves a time machine we all have
access
insurance covers that right uh loki's
got one
we know but he's you know yeah um
he's on someone's payroll the tva uh if
you've got a yeah if you've got like a
silver or gold ppo then that's pretty
good
uh we cut a bunch from this trailer it
was longer um
let's see if any of it should have
stayed in let's roll those deleted
scenes
no the other one on amazon because now
that metadata constructions of the genre
are its own genre
one series will uh have a bunch of
bright colors and keep you laser
animations and stuff
is that different enough no okay what if
they try to make you puke once an
episode
i think we can all agree you're better
without vocal cords
[Applause]
this was this was the cowards cut that i
made
i i blinked in the face of uh of not
wanting
uh trailer to get uh age-gated or
flagged because
i know i know it's animated and
everything and we could have blurred the
whole screen or whatever but i
out of fear cut this because i thought
just the the
30 40 second long montage of gore would
have gotten the trailer like
put behind a wall would you say you've
been silenced by a woke mob
[Laughter]
yes thank you for putting it into words
um
it's exactly this is cancel culture in
action run amok folks yeah i'm gonna
tell the prager university it's not a
mask
it's a muzzle uh and 5g
uh is why your invincible trailer is
centered so
so there you go um yeah that's
definitely our next honest trailer
uh about the my pillow guys q
documentary
everybody needs to hear about this yeah
but there's no commentary we just play
the timeline
all right yeah sorry sorry i cut out all
the gore um i was worried it would get
uh
flagged so anyways keep going
cool hey can someone grab a squeegee the
title card's covered in chum again
okay you're superman and your dad is
thanos you're goku and your dad is
vegeta
mark you are a comic book nerd
there's also amber mark's girlfriend
who's trapped in the skyler for breaking
bad roll
making logical decisions that disappoint
the hero thus making her a villain
sandra oh as a total normie you don't
understand the choices we have to make
you're not a superhero i feel like i'm
standing on the edge of a cliff
and i'm the only one of us who can't fly
your boring old normal mom
more like you i'm nothing special like
a knife to the heart with this one
okay why would you drop the credits like
that the episode clearly isn't over
are you trying to be edgy are you just
scared we're about to switch over to the
tick
this crater is brought to you by the
letter
t starring
the yawn and the restless i learned it
by watching you dad okay
i learned about watching you image
comics man
jk growling world's safest dad
actual non-metaphorical whiplash one
punch man
one punch dad mortal mom said
sandra oh no he didn't drop the hero and
get with the zero
professional fake girlfriends as he
beats beats it
amber is the color of her energy stellar
score guard
agents of heels
wow she really pretty the heck out of
this thing cape fear
the secret identity of the american
teenager
shy hero academia
you know if superheroes really did exist
are we 100 sure they'd all be celebrity
movie stars like on the amazon shows
it's not like nurses or firefighters
ever get booked on the tonight show
i mean if the justice league were real
he would just complain about how long
they took and give them one star yelp
reviews
okay how are their secret identities not
immediately known two people in the
world have ever been able to rock that
mustache
and one is freddie mercury yeah
i just think they they lampshade that in
the in the show
they're like oh yeah i didn't i noticed
that before like they make a point of
being like yeah it's obvious
right or or am i giving it too much
credit
um i think you might be giving it too
much credit because i
i mean and it's all it's they're
constantly flying around without wearing
the
you know they're going off and getting
cheesecake in italy and then flying and
landing directly in front of somebody's
house like it's they're not slick
no they're not the neighbors have to
know they do uh
all these sonic booms uh next door i
feel like this is one of those things
where it uses the fact that the whole
show is meta
to just kind of be like wow so nobody's
going to pay attention to the rules
because we've already put it out there
that we're self-aware and it's like a
you know a deconstruction of all the
tropes
so once you're already there you know
then to go back to be like well what
about the secret on anybody like it's a
deconstruction of all the tropes you
know it's kind of like a get out of
get out of consistency free cards and
they have like a throwaway line of like
if you don't expect to see a superhero
in your high school you don't then you
don't
right i think everyone would expect that
in this world
when there's like four different teen
superhero teams in
america's third largest city so uh yeah
playing a little fast and loose with
that to make the drama work which i
think is you know
okay um all right on to the on to the
questions
uh in the chat so steven summers asked
do we need or want a live action
invincible project after this series
um lonshake lon and danielle shaking
their heads now
uh i think it'd be really hard to match
the tone i mean like visually the tone
um
just the vibrancy and the uh and
this would be a massive massive budget
movie unless you want to kind of dull it
down and then
that's how you get the last airbender do
you want the last airbender because
that's how you get the last airbender
so i think no this is a this is a
perfect animated project let's keep it
let's keep it 2d um
i think it's defined in some ways by
being like over-the-top
violet but if you did that in live
action it cuts your ability to make it
funny and entertaining and light the way
it
the show plays right so i don't know how
you would do that
it would just be gross um
okay uh uh other question from stephen
summers is animation the new thing for
streaming services
where they can spend the money on the
voice cast and the fight scenes to keep
the cost down
um i don't think like i i think that
they uh they went overboard with the
voice cast on this one i feel like they
could have
you don't need mahershala ali to play a
rock man for half an episode like that
money can get you some better
you know looped walking animations or
something like that like
that they uh obviously you need big
stars for like jk simmons and stephen
young
for uh for the main two roles but then
like come on like spread it spread the
wealth around it to the animators or
something like that what what do you
guys think about this
uh is this a trend or or is this a
one-off
um well especially we're seeing a lot of
animation that's going to be coming out
now i think we're going to be seeing
more just because it was like
the thing to kind of produce during the
pandemic so i do think we're going to
see a lot more with like
these really pumped up voice casts so i
don't think that this is going to be the
end of it
yeah i mean it's it's just it's easier
to produce you can do it with a lot of
your team remotely
and so yeah i mean i think it's just
when you're pumping out as much content
as all of these companies are
and you're in an environment where a
show like this or you know like a a hot
anime can become like a huge cultural
thing like an attack on titan or you
know like i think we're just
of course it it's obvious that we're
gonna see a lot more projects like this
and i was actually just reading an
interesting thing about um it was asking
sort of
did netflix screw up by trying to do
jupiter's legacy
in live action like kind of like this if
you wanted to make a whole
milar mark miller world you know world
superhero world might have been easier
to animate it and have all those shows
interact rather than trying to recreate
it in
live action definitely uh mj pretzel
asks
uh well he says would the show be more
violent or about the same if directed by
zack snyder
um i don't think zack snyder would have
picked this
story uh i think he he probably could
have done it
uh back at the turn of the century and
he chose to do
watchmen i mean which is pretty similar
i'd say his version of watchmen it has a
lot in common
with invincible um and i think the
differences are readily apparent but i
think that
i don't think he would have made his uh
his version of this anymore or any less
violent because that's that's pulled
straight from the comics right
yeah except for the subway i don't think
that shot is
is in there is that i don't remember i i
don't remember it's been a minute since
i read it but yeah i don't
uh i don't know that he would have
because this is
like i said or like lon said the
violence on this is
ultra so i don't know that it would have
been able to have the same amount of
violence in a live action
or if uh zachary snyder took it over i
think it would have been
less violent just in terms of the use of
gore
not necessarily in the amount of
punching yeah
i think this it's weird to think of this
in a sniderian
context because this is self-aware
and kind of cheeky and playful and
ironic and
and i don't even mean this is a
criticism of zack snyder but his stuff
is
not that like he's maybe our most
sincere
filmmaker like it's not supposed to be
cheeky
it's not playful this is epic this is
ultimate this is badass this is
essential this is important
it's all about deep themes and you know
like
life and death and so like i don't think
invincible is the sort of thing that
interests him i think something that's
weightier and heavier and more
thoughtful and with with
grander stakes that isn't just like okay
now it's just about this kid in high
school it's like
no it's about the fate of the universe
you know like so i think watchmen is
it makes much more sense for zack snyder
than in vince
all right i'm curious about this one a
little off topic but i'll take it uh mac
attack 423 s
you have any good audio book
recommendations i i could use some too
so i'm i'm all ears you guys do audio
books
and and failing that books
no no no books no i mean
like just fiction we're just
recommending facebook yeah just throw a
book out there to give the people
something that
to tie them over till next week's
episode well one thing i recommended
fiction a lot
uh that i'm a big fan of is a sci-fi
author named ian banks he wrote a series
called the culture
sure that are not not as well known even
among sci-fi fans i find but are
terrific i
would start with player of games that's
a fun yeah that's a great book
uh i i can second that danielle any
books
oh man the last book that i read on tape
or that i listened to on tape was that
twilight
that's all through uh all through
edward's uh
perspective because i wanted to i wanted
to listen to the worst thing
and who boy i got it so if you're into
something that's a little uh
weird and you're listening to a
sociopath talk about how a girl smells
uh this is the book on tape for you
i'd like to hear of several hundred year
old man's adventures in high school that
sounds uh that sounds thrilling
uh one other one i'll recommend that i
recently read uh a fred got it for me is
mark frost's novel the secret history
of twin peaks that like takes you
through the whole
sort of like long history of the town
and spotlights all kinds of other
it's all kinds of background stuff if
you're a fan of that show but it's
really
it's really neat and it is written as
like a novel
well there you go um i don't do
audiobooks uh i can recommend some
podcasts but
but books that i'm sure have audio
versions i just read this
book i don't even know how to pronounce
it um because i didn't do the audiobook
cerse
or sirsa uh by madeleine miller which is
a
it's a it's a book from the perspective
of kind of a
minor deity uh who gets exiled and then
all the all the great
heroes and gods of of greek and uh uh
literature i don't know the homeric
people kind of stopped by their eyes
c-i-r-c-e like
isn't that cersei let's say cersei i
thought that's how you say that
but it's super good writing and uh and
i'm sure will be
an angelina jolie movie in in two to
four years
so so check that one out let me know
what you think um that's it for this
week's show
uh this week's book report so
i can't watch those can't watch those
but we will soon um
all things get adapted on a long enough
timeline and uh
and on a long enough timeline we will be
back next week um to do
a episode that will absolutely
slay so that's your clue for next week
uh lon danielle thank you for joining us
at youtube audience we'll see you next
time on australia commentaries bye-bye
[Music]
you